然後請大家到作業二的地方
在0916的課程裡面
作業二拍GNT繪製地圖
然後底下有一個附件
我們把這個附件下載到你的電腦
這是第一步
就是把11class上面的這個檔案
IPYMB檔下載到你的本機電腦裡面
然後你就會看到有一個檔案在下載區
和這個檔
好
這第一步哦
第一步就這個
扣這個
我把它步驟寫下來好了
然後第一步呢
就是download
下載這個檔案
IPYMB檔
就是這個
然後從ex上下載
這第一步
然後第二步
開啟Google的雲端硬碟
然後
make a folder
先建立一個資料夾
然後這個資料夾名字叫做Geophysics 2026
名稱大家可以自己改
建立資料夾會比較方便
之後可以找到這個檔案
這個檔案我把它完整名稱複製下來
就download這個檔
然後接下來就是把這個檔案
upload這個檔案到Google Drive的那個folder裡面
然後第四步
第四步很簡單
就是在Google Drive直接點那個檔
所以總共這四個步驟
我們把它做完
先到eClass下載這個檔案
然後開啟Google Drive
建立一個目錄
然後再把這個檔案上傳到剛剛的目錄
然後直接點它就可以了
好
我們來做這個動作
到那個雲端硬碟
然後我們新增一個目錄
好
那找一下那個目錄在哪
在這裡
那它應該是空的
因為是一個新的目錄
然後接著就新增
然後檔案上傳
然後找到剛剛從EEKS上面下載
下來的檔案
然後按開啟
它就會被上傳到這裡
好
那接下來第四步就是直接點它
他然後他就會用那個google code label的方式去開啟他
然後接著就可以
執行他
那我們就
然後第二步因為他是clone到我的
所以我不太確定你們
能不能clone我的
還是要改成你的
這個要請你們幫我試一下
如果你直接按
按過去會不會應該是可以啦
不一定要clone我
你們的可問我的應該也可以
好反正這邊就是給他按
大家可以直接按全部執行
然後他就會每一個都RUN一遍
然後RUN到第三步的時候
他這邊就會開始安裝那個PyGND
因為我們剛剛就是卡在這個PyGND沒有
好那這個這個好像有這個好像有問題
好但他其實是要RUN這個程式
所以其實我們可以把這個程式直接扣過來就好了
就不用git clone了
不用弄得那麼複雜
所以我再修改一下那個步驟
讓它更簡單一點
好 等一下新的程式會長這樣
那我先把它整體一下
前面是安裝環境
然後後面就是程式碼
然後再就會產生圖檔
那我們等一下要改的地方會在這裡
他有給我們提示
我們可以改區域改時間
搜尋地震的那個最小規模
還有剖面的範圍
然後剖面的寬度
然後最大的深度
然後還有疏疏的圖片的檔密
然後可以改這個
他這樣跑完之後
他會產生兩個檔案
檔案會放在這裡
你可以點他
就可以從這邊看到那個圖檔
那我們只要改這個程式
的這個地方圖就跟著改
那你可以把這個輸出的圖檔跟著改
然後這樣子
我覺得還蠻
蠻好操作的
所以應該就用這個版本
我把它再改一下名字叫做new
等一下同學用這個版本
為了怕那個跟剛剛的版本混淆
所以我們給他一個新的名字
請大家用這個版本
我先把它存檔
然後再下載
然後我在eClass這邊再更新一下
這個就不要用這個檔案了
我們現在用新的檔案
那步驟還是一樣
就是先下載這個檔
就點一下就下載了
然後到 Google Drive 開一個目錄
然後把這個檔案上傳到 Google Drive
然後點它
所以剛剛已經做過了
這個是
它已經 因為我的已經
你可以先把你的舊的檔案給刪掉
然後重新再上傳一次檔案
新的檔案後面有個 new
然後再點它
它就會用Colab把它開啟
當然要注意就是
Colab它有個限制就是一次只能開一個Session
你不能開好幾個Colab
然後一起Run
你一次只能開一個
因為好像
這樣你會佔用它太多資源
除非你有付費
它有可能可以開好多格
然後開啟來之後會看到第一個就是安裝環境
第二格也是裝環境
然後第三格就是程式的部分
然後大概就這三個部分
就可以讓同學開始進行作業
那我們可以直接按這個全部執行
然後讓他跑一遍
所以現在就比較簡單
大家用檔案下載
然後用Google Drive
然後點他就可以執行
不過這個檔案還是希望可以跟GitHub聯動
所以它等一下有一個複製跟貼上的
這裡可以在GitHub中儲存副本
所以你一樣可以再把這個檔案再存回去GitHub
這樣子它才能夠儲存在雲端的GitHub空間裡面
那未來你可以用其他的程式去跟你的那個檔案做互動或者溝通
Change VTR Cursor或者其他的AI工具
或者你自己本基端的Integrity都可以跟你的這個新的程式跟檔案可以溝通
好現在看起來它就是這個安裝會裝比較久
那我們就就是先不理它擺著
那現在先下課一下
我們等一下休息到20分好了
然後看一下我們今天的課程的規劃
等一下還是會進行
抽兩位同學來報告作業一的內容
那報告完之後呢
我就會把你的分數登記在
作業四
不是作業四
口頭報告一里面
就這邊等一下抽到兩位同學
要請你把你的
你的作業儀的
那個GitHub的連結上傳到這裡來
就表示你交了
你進行你完成了那個口頭報告
那我的分數就會依照這個地方去
打分數
然後下一次我們還會再安排口頭報告
就再從還沒被抽到的同學去
去抽
所以這邊到最後就會
每個人都會有報告到
只是就是分批一次
然後不一定什麼時候會被抽到這樣子
但是最後一定都會每個人都有成績
這樣子我們比較好掌控那個時間
因為不太可能一次讓所有的人
所有的人都報告過一遍
好那11點20回來的時候
我們等一下來抽一下那個
兩位幸運的同學
然後11點半的時候
的時候我們來進行這個活動這樣子
然後現在我們
剛剛在做是作業二的部分
如果有問題等一下下課可以再問老師
好那我們先下課11點20再回來